Just add water and throw on some Instant Underpants.
Right after you sign this Bathroom Guest Book.
Because LÜT is back!
Start your day with a cup of Joe using Canadiano
a personalized wooden coffee maker that uses
a pour over coffee method and is carved out
of Cherry, Walnut, or Maple which over time
slowly absorbs the flavor of each cup you
make.
Once its ready drink it from the Toasty Mug
to keep your hands warm.
If there's no time for coffee just add this
Caffeinated Maple Syrup to your breakfast.
That you eat out of a Bacon Bowl.
Or just wear your breakfast with Power Bacon
Deodorant, for when you sweat.... like a pig.
Pig out on Glow in the Dark Ice Cream at Lick
Me I'm Delicious, a portable ice cream company
that will come to your event and make awesome
frozen creations using either the nitro ice
cream parlor or the nitro ice cream buggy.
Network like a carnivore during your event
by handing out some Meat Business Cards.
But be sure to charge your iPhone first in
this toaster dock.
If you have a thing that needs to be charged
use the Thing Charger, to charge your things....
all of the things!
Get back to basics with one of these human
powered devices.
After tripling their goal on Kickstarter the
guys at Pedal Power are now ready to create
and ship your personalized machine or choose
from their two stock products, the Big Rig
or the Pedal Genny.
If you're pedaling a bike use these Turn Signal
Gloves to be safe.
They help you to be seen by motorists with
just the push of your thumb.
Then use your thumb to play with your Smart
Plane that is crash proof, connected instantly
by touching your phone to the plane and flies
for half an hour on a single charge.
Charge into battle with this awesome Rubber
Band Machine Gun and do this to everything.
Let your feline friend battle this Egg Cat
Toy that mimics and responds to your cat like
a smart little egg companion.
See how smart your friends are by giving them
the gift of puzzles with this cryptic puzzle
pod that lets you set your own 5 letter code.
Drink up with this shark attack glass .
And use Shark Fin Ice cubes to fill it keep
your drink cold.
Act like a shark with Face Rig.
An indiegogo campaign that lets you become
a character that even displays emotions using
just a webcam.
Keep your feet warm with these Rechargeable
Heated Insoles.
Or by using a fireplace anywhere.
With the Anywhere Fireplace.
That you can set on your light up coffee table
that let's you choose your own colors and
graphics for the table top.
For some prehistoric light use this Dino Lamp.
Or a Wall Torch Sconce that even detaches
to take along on your adventures.
And create the perfect temperature with your
Bed Jet that goes from toasty to cool with
the touch of a button.
Then cuddle up with your Custom Stuffed Animal
made from your childhood drawings courtesy
of Budsies.com.
That may or may not end up looking similar
to these Killer Bunny Slippers.
Which pair wonderfully with Enemies Socks.
The Smarty Ring shows you to see incoming
and outgoing call notifications, alerts you
to text messages and emails, and updates from
social media.
And once you're 30 meters away from your phone
it beeps to remind you.
But for a mere $944 you can own this Meteorite
and Dinosaur Ring.
So tell everyone what's on your mind with
Roller Notes.
Keep everything else in this Stuff I Want
to Hide From Nosy People Box.
And as always - thanks for watching!